here's what's going on at the movies  who's Elliot flying into theaters this  weekend is Pete's dragon a fantastic  family adventure about a boy and his  fire-breathing best friend for a dose of  inspiration check out Florence Foster  Jenkins  the true story of an heiress who wasn't  afraid to chase her dreams go to  Florence you must go on  the r-rated animated comedy sausage  party serves up a twisted tale of one  hot dog search for the truth and folks  this one's definitely not for kids and  finally let's find out what's hot in  theaters this weekend with this week's  fantasy patience  so what's your weekend ticket going to  be let us know in the comments below  we'll see you next time on weekend  ticket  you